i didn't really know that bed rest was
like in bed i honestly thought bed rest
was you have to really really really
relax
stay home i thought it could be couch
rest now i'm in trouble
so now i need bad rest chrissy teigen
didn't
exactly follow the doctor's orders and
now she's paying the price
just letting everyone know that if i
have to bail on anything
it's because i'm on like super serious
bed rest
times the 34 year old model is pregnant
with her and her hubby john legend's
third child
and earlier this month she revealed
she'd been given a strict order from her
doc
tweeting quote i'm on official two-week
bed rest
i'm taking this time to learn how to sew
capes and kid clothes so she is about to
get
astonishingly ugly but on tuesday
chrissy told her insta followers that
despite taking it easy
she hadn't actually been spending all
her time in bed
i didn't really know that bed rest was
like in bed i honestly thought bed rest
was you have to really really really
relax
stay home i thought it could be couch
rest now i'm in trouble
so now i need bad rest now she says
she's on super serious bed rest times
adding that she's just trying to be as
healthy as possible
chrissy also noted that this has been
her most challenging pregnancy yet
it's a bit of a difficult pregnancy i
feel good though
but yeah i will say i'm probably being
punished for talking so much about
how great the first two went i was like
oh yeah
pregnant's awesome now i get it
i get anyone that thinks it's not so
awesome
but very happy to
be carrying this baby the cookbook
author also tweeted about bed rest
revealing she spent all but five minutes
in bed in the last
24 hours adding that the mandate lasts
until next
tuesday lord it's kind of crappier than
it sounds
on punishment for saying the first two
pregnancies were easy peasy
of course chrissy and john already share
a four-year-old daughter luna
and a two-year-old son miles and the
proud mama recently shared
this sweet clip of her little girl
helping her get an ultrasound
writing in the caption that all is well
how do you see doctor
back in 2018 when chrissy was pregnant
with miles
john couldn't help but gush about their
growing family
it's always exciting because you never
know what they're going to be like you
never know
you know anything you're just excited
that
another product of your relationship and
your love is going to be out there in
front of you
and uh we're just excited to see how
we're going to be as
parents of two and how luna is going to
be at the big sister
it's going to be really exciting and fun